more than two dozen manhattan parents
filing a lawsuit against the city
demanding the full reopening of
schools the suit argues that the
inability to offer
full five day a week in-person
instruction with teachers in the
classroom
is a violation of the state constitution
three parents who helped organize the
effort which has raised nearly thirty
thousand dollars
join me now natalya maroukha
allison wenger and stephanie coconos
they all join
me good morning to you all so the youth
three helped organize this lawsuit
against
the new york city department of
education and mayor bill de blasio
natalia i'll start with you why do you
think this lawsuit is necessary and what
are you hoping to achieve
well we have have watched our kids and
other kids in our
in our city be locked out of classrooms
since march of 2020
and we kept hoping for a plan we thought
that the administration had our kids
best
interest we thought any day now we'll be
able to get every kid back into school
like other cities have
and they have across europe and that
hasn't happened
so we've advocated we've rallied
we've marched we've begged we've tweeted
we've done everything we could
and now it's time to compel the city to
do the right thing
so many kids are still shut out of
classrooms and it's unacceptable we
cannot wait another day
yeah alison you know same question to
you why do you think legal action is
necessary and also how did
at-home learning affect your children
um you know i think it's necessary
because we keep hearing from dr
fauci from our governor from our mayor
they all keep saying how clear the data
is that school is safe and that kids
should be in school so it's
confusing on why our kids aren't back at
school full time when so many
desperately want to be back
and you know they're truly suffering my
kids um
fortunately just went back uh full time
that remote was really really difficult
for them
it was hard they're seven years old it's
hard to focus on a computer screen on
worksheets
our teachers did an amazing job as best
as they could
but it's just difficult for you know
kids to be learning this way
in a they're in an isolated environment
oh my gosh where are they
they're not with their yeah friends it
so is
and i know you have two um
seven-year-old twins so good for you
stephanie you have a five-year-old and a
seven-year-old
your kids also uh went back to school
already um and have you seen a change
in them from what they were like when
they were learning at home versus
now that they're back in school it's
it's night and day honestly i mean
when you have a five-year-old trying to
learn
social skills and life skills in front
of a screen it's just not age
appropriate and they are
flourishing right now with their
teachers yeah
absolutely natalia your children you
have a seven-year-old and a ten-year-old
and um mayor bill de blasio he actually
uh spoke out yesterday about
school reopenings i want you to take a
listen to what he had to say watch
we made our schools the safest places in
new york city the comeback of the new
york city schools biggest school system
in the nation
the fact that we reopen our schools when
so many other cities didn't even dare to
try
and i want everybody back in school
in september everybody two takeaways
from that
on my end is that he thinks that he
handled schools his administration
handled
schools in new york city in a really
great way and he also does say that he
wants schools to be
back full-time in the fall does that
give you any comfort
sure it gives me a lot of comfort but it
doesn't actually give me anything
binding
and doesn't show that there is a plan
that
parents can truly rely on he's also the
one who said that new york city has had
a gold standard of reopening
i would disagree i would say that places
like braille new jersey where they
didn't shut down
entire schools for two unrelated cases
and kept kids in school
pretty much full time from early this
year
that would probably be my sense of what
a gold standard is
so i i believe the mayor wants to do the
right thing
i think his heart is in the right place
i think he's hamstrung
by people like michael mulgrew and randy
weingarten
who have extorted the city and this
country and have kept blue swathes
of this country shut down at the kids
expense
and they are spinning this story to make
it look like they're trying to reopen
but in fact
we have no confidence that they have the
kids best interests at heart
and we know that the only way to do this
is to actually do this lawsuit take
action
yeah and allison have you gotten any um
plan
in place about what happens if next year
and your kids do go back to in person
and then
a child tests positive for kovid what
happens to the classroom has anybody
told you anything about that
there's been no plans nothing there's no
plans on
you know i know mayor de blasio said
that that he wants that but there's no
plans there's nothing he's announced
that
new york city is opening up we have
theaters and broadway and it's really
exciting but he has not mentioned
the plan for how new york city schools
are going to open and the parents are
very nervous
and we're scrambling yeah stephanie have
you heard anything about how
uh the fall is going to be handled i
don't i mean i do know that we are still
testing our children weekly so we are
testing our children asymptomatically
and any time that there is a covid
positive case
regardless if it is a false negative or
a false positive rather
um our classrooms are closed so even
though we are back and we are
some elementary schools are back five
days
we still are going to continue classroom
closures
unnecessarily all right well you three
are taking action you know we reached
out
um to mayor de blasio's office and the
new york city department of education
but have not heard back in the meantime
we thank all three of you for joining